good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock how worried should we be about
this new strain of coronavirus we're
being asked to follow new rules to stop
the spread of omicron pupils and
secondary schools will have to wear
masks in communal areas and from
tomorrow face coverings will be required
in shops and also on public transport
along with tougher rules on
international travel we'll be gathering
views from the government scientists a
travel expert and also a former prime
minister
also this morning the long-awaited sex
trafficking trial of the disgraced
financier jeffrey epstein's
ex-girlfriend gilead maxwell is set to
begin
in new york city and
hi guys like to hear you
and we'll hear from the amazon
adventurer who walked more than 250
miles through one of the last unexplored
wildernesses on earth it's monday the
29th of november
boosting the boosters the government's
vaccine advisors are expected to issue
new guidance on rapid expansion of the
programme to tackle the omicron variant
today
i'm at london waterloo station speaking
to travelers about the new rules
a 14 year old boy will appear in court
charged with a murder of 12 year old ava
white in liverpool
france's message to the government make
the uk less attractive to migrants to
stop people crossing the channel in
small boats
prince charles flies into barbados amid
a row over comments in a new book and
the end of formal ties between the
island nation and the monarchy
hailed as a genius of the fashion
industry the artistic director of louis
vuitton virgil abloh has died at the age
of 41.
[Music]
okay let's get right to it should we
what's going on with this uh new variant
of the virus how worried should we be
the uh health minister edward argo is
with me in the studio good morning good
morning kate how old are you
well what we're doing is we've taken
swift precautionary steps we don't fully
understand this new variant at all yet
it's got 50 mutations roughly
of which 32 are in the spike protein the
bit that connects the key to our cells
and infects us so that is concerning
but it's still early days in terms of
understanding how it actually reacts in
terms of transmissibility in terms of
how dangerous it is therefore let's let
the scientists do their work but we've
taken some proportionate measured steps
to help slow down the spread and the
seeding of that variant while they do
their work hopefully it won't be
a huge concern but we don't know we've
got to be precautionary in this south
african medical association the chairman
of that saying the symptoms are very
very mild well i did see that report and
i think that um that doctor was talking
about
uh symptoms in predominantly younger
people that they'd experienced it in we
don't know how it will react in terms of
older people or with the vaccine so
hopefully that is what we will see
not just in south africa but around the
world but we've just taken those
precautionary steps while we seek to
understand how it works is it about now
when we think you know what we should
have given them more of the vaccines for
kovacs we've only given 11 of what we
promised well if you look at south
africa i think um the president of south
africa or government officials have said
there is no shortage of vaccines in
south africa
which is where we've seen this new
variant i'm originating from the great
but but then if we're looking more
broadly and i think you and i spoke
about this um when last you interviewed
me
we've pledged 100 million doses by next
june we've delivered i think you're
absolutely right about 11 of that so far
we're on target to deliver just over a
third of that uh have delivered over a
third of that by the end of this month
and then we will deliver the rest next
year i think that's a
um a reasonable and swift roll out and
we're still i think the second biggest
donor supplier of vaccines through the
kovacs vote program after the united
states i think so can we do more and do
we need to ramp it up yes but are we on
target to deliver on that pledge yes we
are okay so let's talk about what's
going on at home then give us an update
this morning how many cases have we got
so there are three you'll have seen in
the news overnight three confirmed cases
i'll be honest with you and your viewers
i would expect that to rise um we don't
know by what speed or by what numbers so
therefore what we're doing is trying to
slow it down but we're clear we can't
stop it
and we're trying to give ourselves the
time to understand how it works and how
it interacts
with the vaccine but that's why we're
putting in place these sensible
precautionary measures to help slow it
down you say slow it down but the
flights were coming in from south africa
people were allowed to get off the plane
mingle with hundreds of other passengers
coming from wherever and then go home we
saw in amsterdam people were isolated on
the airplanes and they had their checks
before they were allowed off well i
think we've moved possibly globally
among if not the fastest countries in
the world i think south africa
identified the genomic sequencing on
tuesday
on thursday even before this was
designated as a variant of concern which
happened on friday i think from who on
thursday we'd already set out my boss
sajid javid had set out um very swift
steps to tackle this both in terms of
borders but also in terms of the plans
around um around testing
so i think we might have to get off the
plane i think we moved very swiftly when
people were returning or were in flight
um they were met by health officials um
we would expect them to travel to take
that pcr test and of course now we've
got the 10 countries i think it is on
the red list we will be expecting people
before they travel to have booked a
quarantine hotel so i think we moved
very swiftly proportionately but swiftly
and tackled that what there always is
which is the moment you make an
announcement like this
there are calls for people for you to
delay it to give people more time
they're others saying do it to me i
think we've struck the right balance
here in providing that um
that that response but allowing people
to get home what about people who are in
south africa and other countries they're
ready to come back and now they have to
pay 2 250 pounds to stay in a hotel
could be a family of four that's ten
thousand pounds that they don't have
what happens there well i think i do
appreciate that's extremely difficult
for people who will have gone on holiday
gone to visit family or gone for family
events
and suddenly find that this has changed
sadly we've seen over the past year and
a half year and three quarters this is
the nature of this virus we can never
with total predictability guarantee when
someone um travels abroad that there
won't be
something of this sort now we've managed
to avoid that largely in recent months
i think the last new variant we saw was
we only just came off the red list
didn't it and and yet some families now
could be ten thousand pounds in debt
through no fault of their own absolutely
i'm afraid that that's sadly and i'm
very sympathetic to that but that's
sadly the nature of this virus and what
it does
you're right it did come off the list
pre the identification of this new
variant we've always been clear that was
a risk the new variant um credit all
credit to south africa for its amazing
genomic sequencing and testing program
that identified this new variant very
swiftly and they told us they told the
world they were very open about that
and they've been exemplary and how
they've done that but sadly until we
understand it we've got to take those
penalized for being so open well i don't
think they're being
penalized for being open we've seen with
other countries
when are variants identified we've got
to take as have other countries the
necessary steps to help stop that
seeding and spreading other countries i
think have been even tougher on some of
their board research i think i may be
wrong that israel has closed its borders
overnight and other countries are
putting in different levels so each
country is reacting in its own way we
believe that we've reacted in a
proportionate and measured way um to
help address the challenge of this event
while we seek to understand it so what
else are we doing here
the booster program what's going on so
the best program the secretary of state
sergey javid as you will know has asked
the jcvi the joint committee on
vaccinations and immunizations for
advice urgently on a the
bringing down the gap potentially
between
first uh between second and booster jabs
but also in terms of whether the booster
program should be extended downwards in
terms of age range we're awaiting that
advice i hope it will come hopefully
later today i don't want to pre-judge it
i don't know so our understanding is
that it's anybody over 18 gets a booster
but i think that's what they are looking
at i don't know what they're going to
recommend i haven't seen the advice you
you and your team may have done but i
haven't yet because i don't think it's
been formally delivered but we'd expect
that within the next within the coming
hours okay so so sometime today we'll
hear that's my what's happening and the
gap between the second booster and that
second vaccine and the booster that
could come down to five months
potentially but we'll wait for their
advice that's that's what they're there
for and we will look very carefully
advice they give us hopefully in the
next few hours okay um
as far as the symptoms are concerned we
don't how do we actually know
whether people have got the omicron
variant or it's the delta variant or
whether because the symptoms are very
similar they are and that's why we're
recommending and we recommend people
with symptoms um you know you and i and
others will probably be taking lateral
flow tests if not daily every couple of
days or similar or regularly what we're
saying to people with symptoms is that
they should take a pcr test because the
pcr test gives the facility to do the
genomic sequencing that helps us
identify which are omicron which are
delta
the lateral flow test won't do that but
the pcrs will and therefore when people
have symptoms or if they test positive
on a lateral flow again that's why we're
advising a pcr test to allow for that
genomic sequence so why did we do away
with the pcr test for people coming back
from holiday
we reacted in what we thought was a
proportionate way to the level both of
threat and knowledge we had of existing
yeah this every time and again this
virus has shown us that we can't be
complacent which is exactly what you
were saying we struck an appropriate
balance there we still had the
surveillance program which allows us to
genomically sequence
through pcr to understand where the new
variants are coming through and we have
to strike about this it goes back to
your point just now okay again about the
price of things the uh the ability for
people to go abroad on holiday we think
we've struck the right balance but when
a new variant comes along we got that
through genomic sequencing we're now
using pcr tests just to identify where
that is in the communi if it gets into
the community more broadly but
particularly for travelers coming into
this country so we were risking the
health of the nation because of cheap
natural floating i don't think we were
risking it because i think on the basis
of why have we changed on the basis of
on the basis of what we were seeing with
existing variants and knowledge of them
as scientists understood those existing
variants lateral flow tests and similar
were appropriate what we're seeing now
is a new variant
while we seek to understand that over
the next two three weeks which is
hopefully all it will take for
scientists to be able to actually
understand transmissibility
how dangerous it is impact on vaccines
it's right that we use the pcrs to
better understand that genomic sequence
and where it may have spread in the
community as i say i would expect i'm
afraid more cases in this country but we
need to work out where they are um how
long do you expect the red list to be in
place for well we will we'll follow the
evidence but in three weeks time the
prime minister and secretary of state
christmas eve so just shy of i think but
um we'll review
the mark wearing and the travel
restrictions
in a second of course that gives that
gives enough time for us to see how this
disease behaves we know that you and i
have talked about it many times the lag
time between infection between
becoming ill between serious illness and
equally it gives the scientists time to
do that work on this so it gives enough
time to understand the impact of it but
people who book their christmas holidays
what are you saying to them cancel them
no what we're saying is follow the
they're all red uh
red list countries you know they're all
people shouldn't be traveling to
themselves it's difficult
in this context
of counseling
but what we've said is if people are
coming back from south africa we've put
in place the quarantine hotels that's
again from what you were just saying
quite rightly you highlight that's a a
big cost and i think people will think
about that very carefully other
countries
we've said um pcr testing etc we're not
saying cancel your holidays to france or
other countries but we have put in place
that proportionate um testing and border
control people who are going to a
redless country is on the red list at
the moment they really shouldn't be well
what i'd i'll be honest and i've said it
before is we cannot say what will happen
there over the coming weeks and
therefore going to to your earlier point
in traveling at the moment with this
virus particularly with a new variant
around there is an element of of risk
there for people so you review that
before three weeks we need to have the
three weeks in order to understand how
this new variant works i hope that the
uh
the scientists and those researching it
will get more information more quickly
and actually one of the things we did
last week was we were
open as quickly as we could be with the
british people about what we were
finding even without fully knowing how
this new variant worked we wanted to
level the british people which is what
my boss the secretary of state did last
week mask wearing you you mentioned you
touched on that it's gonna be tricky for
your boss isn't it your big boss he's
never wearing a mask i don't think so i
think um he will comply with the rules
um just as we all do i was when i was
sitting out um
when not being interviewed when i was
sitting out in your in your lobby
earlier i was wearing my mask took it
off to do interviews and then we'll put
it on again when i leave your studio i
think everyone will do that
for example in shops or when in shops or
on public transport that's what we've
said that's what we will be putting in
the regulations and we would expect
everyone to come why not pubs and
restaurants i mean can you not catch
covered in a pub well equally in pubs
restaurants hospitality venues partly
we've always seen this throughout the
pandemic people are eating drinking etc
clearly impractical to wear a mask in
those circumstances say a restaurant a
lot of time is spent sitting down with
your group with whoever you've come with
family friends are in a pub should you
put your masters in ordering on that
again
on that we're not making it a legal
requirement but people will make their
own judgment why not
because we believe that shops and public
transport often very confined spaces
take a pass to a london pub
it's mad
taking well hang on i'll come on to that
um we think that's a proportionate um
response it's a measured response while
we understand how this variant works we
don't believe
we need to or should they do that in
hospitality or restaurant venues at this
point and hopefully we won't need to
make any further changes hopefully in
three weeks we'll be able to scale back
um what we've done but we just
being honest we don't know how this
virus and with this new variant behaves
yet so we've got to be measured into
this crowded pub standing at the bar
surely you should have to wear your mask
then no i think well if you're standing
at the bar chances are you're ordering a
drink and then drinking a drink um and
therefore you won't be wearing masks
while you're drinking your drinks i
think you go and get your drink and then
you go back to your table
but that's but you're only going to be
doing that for a brief period go to the
bar or your drink and come back if
you're in a tube on a bus you're likely
to be on there 15 minutes 20 minutes
half an hour and we go back you've been
interviewing me now for a year and a
half almost two years and when we were
first talking about this we talked about
both distance but also the length of
time you're in close proximity to an
individual therefore we think this is we
think this is proportionate and it's the
right precautionary balance to strike
okay we are out of time but um i mean i
have to have some sympathy for you when
when are we going to see the back of
this virus well i think the whole
country wants to see the back of this um
virus as such a javits said the pandemic
isn't over
yet and we've seen that with this new
variant but we are in a hugely different
place to where we were as chris whittie
said with any of the previous new
variants that vaccination program has
made a huge difference in protecting our
citizens protecting our society and
enabling us to open up and the measures
we're putting in place now as i say are
proportionate they're measured while we
understand how this works so i think
we've made huge strides forward and i'm
looking forward to a christmas spent
with family and friends okay and finally
could we possibly find ourselves in a
position where you tighten the rules up
even further within the next three weeks
it's not something i'm anticipating oh
i'd like to hear that good to talk to
you thank you minister i really
appreciate it thank you remember where
you heard it first uh let's have a look
what the papers are saying this morning
thank you minister it's not too much to
mask says the metro as masks are set to
become mandatory again in shops and
public transport in england
from tomorrow
and the eye leads with news that face
masks will also be required again in
communal areas of schools in england
from today but new requirements for
everyone including children to isolate
if they come into contact with an
omicron case will cause chaos in schools
that's according to the telegraph
the guardian says new restrictions are
likely to come with a widening of the
booster jab programmed to stem the
spread of the virus that's also the lead
in the daily mail with a paper saying
all over eight teens will be offered a
booster
the mirror calls it the fight to save
christmas
meantime the government is to make
musk's mandatories we were saying on
public transport due to the emergence of
the omicron variant with the rules
coming into place from tomorrow our
reporter aisha zaid is at london's
waterloo station for us this morning
good morning good morning so you don't
have to wear a mask at the pub but you
will have to wear one where you are good
morning aisha how's that being received
this morning
morning k well it's been a big mixed bag
of opinions here that's right from
tomorrow people will have to wear face
coverings when traveling on public
transport in england i have to say
looking around waterloo station today
it's very much a 50 50 split if not more
people not wearing masks than those who
are which is likely to look very
different from tomorrow we've spoken to
a few people traveling this morning and
it has been mixed opinions some people
really welcoming the move they feel the
government's making the right decision
one commuter told me that she's glad
it's being made mandatory again because
she has felt unsafe traveling to work
over the last few months but other
people quite frankly fed up they don't
want to see masks coming back
but one thing that virtually everyone
i've spoken to has agreed upon is a
question over what compliance will look
like when the mandate was dropped back
in july network rails said that only 20
of people traveling on trains were
wearing face coverings and it's
something that several unions for travel
workers have expressed concerns over how
many people will wear masks when
it is re-introduced now all of this
comes in a bid to target that omicron
variant it's a variant the worst one yet
according to x but three cases
identified in the uk so far brentwood
nottingham and another from a person
traveling through the west minster area
the prime minister said that this is one
of several measures which the prime
minister has said
is only going to be temporary and
proportionate
and that measures will be reviewed in
three weeks time so it will be a case of
waiting to see what happens next as
scientists work out more about the
omicron variant okay thank you aisha
thank you
still to come on the programme for you
this morning as the long-awaited sex
trafficking trial for gillane maxwell
begins in new york at half seven gonna
be speaking to a lawyer who's acted on
behalf of some of jeffrey epstein's
victims
according to eight speaking to the chair
of the south african medical association
with the doctor who first spotted the
new omicron variant
and the new covalent variant raised
concerns about the lack of vaccines in
poor countries i'm going to be speaking
to the former prime minister gordon
brown
50 pub goers have spent their third
night snowed in at the tan hill inn in
the yorkshire dales will be hearing from
the manager at 20 to 9.
the trial of gilead maxwell former
socialite and long-time friend of
geoffrey epstein is due to begin in new
york later on today prosecutors will
argue that she recruited and groomed
girls for the disgraced financier to
abuse charges that she denies on the eve
of the trial her brother has told sky
news he is relieved it's about to get
underway from new york joe pike reports
she mixed with the rich and famous
was a friend of princess and presidents
i've met her numerous times over the
years i wish her well
but it's gillane maxwell's links to
pedophile jeffrey epstein that means
she's now due in court on trial after
decades of explosive abuse allegations
and facing the fight of her life
given where we are in this moment of
time with the metoo movement this is the
first time you've got
a woman
on and
so publicly on trial for these kind of
crimes vicki ward has been investigating
jeffrey epstein for almost 20 years
one of the reasons
this trial has attracted so much
attention because the idea that
a
privileged
educated woman with seemingly every
advantage is alleged to have done this
to
helpless underage females there's
something
so unspeakably
awful about that gillane maxwell denies
grooming underage girls so jeffrey
epstein could sexually abuse them the
crimes are alleged to have taken place
at epstein's various mansions including
this one in manhattan galaine maxwell is
facing six counts of sex trafficking
between 1994 and 2004 against four
alleged victims prosecutors say the
youngest was 14 years old
jeffrey epstein died in prison in 2019
while awaiting trial in an apparent
suicide
within months gillane maxwell was
arrested on this remote estate and
imprisoned she was refused bail six
times and at one point appeared to have
a black eye
her family claim she's being mistreated
both kielen
and the family are relieved that we are
finally getting to the moment of truth
and this trial is about to begin
it's been
over 500 days now that she has been in
isolation in prison
but the decision over whether she takes
the stand has yet to be made a defendant
testifying is always risky because the
defendant will open him or herself up to
cross-examination to examination as to
prior bad acts to prior criminal conduct
to prior possibly even immoral conduct
it has yet to be revealed exactly what
evidence prosecutors will present here
at court and who is cooperating with
them but pre-trial hearings suggest they
will call an expert witness on grooming
and show the jury a contacts book this
trial may not be the last in the epstein
saga but whatever the verdict many hope
it will provide some answers about the
two mysterious figures at its heart joe
pike sky news new york
prince of wales is in barbados for a
ceremony to mark the caribbean island
ending its formal ties with the monarchy
and becoming a republic the visit takes
place amid a row over accusations in a
new book that he questioned the future
skin tone of harry and meghan's children
at the time of their engagement a palace
source said this is fiction and not
worth further comment the heir to the
throne is in barbados at the invitation
of the country's prime minister and is
expected to reaffirm the uk's close and
continuing relationship with the island
nation
french interior minister has said the uk
needs to make itself less attractive to
migrants who want to try to cross the
channel gerald damenin was speaking
after a meeting of his european
counterparts from which the home
secretary priti patel was invited but
then excluded from calais ali foreski
reports after tragedy there's often
politics
and as ministers in charge of migration
from france belgium germany and the
netherlands gathered in calais notably
absent the british home secretary
pretty patel did speak to the dutch
migration minister she said they talked
about the importance of agreements to
return migrants but she was disinvited
from the summit after boris johnson was
accused of not being serious enough in a
statement the home secretary said that
the uk will continue to push for greater
cooperation with eu partners because
failure to do so she said could result
in even worse scenes in freezing water
during the coming months
behind the scenes things were always
kind of working well and there was still
always a lot of cooperation going on
what is different now is that the
relationship behind the scenes too has
genuinely deteriorated
both sides are playing to a domestic
audience too with the french president
fighting a presidential election from
the right and in britain boris johnson
who pledged to take back control of our
borders there had been hope that a human
tragedy would refocus minds beyond
politics but it may just have hardened
the resolve on both sides
on the british side of the channel many
came to remember whatever the politics
this is about 27 people who lost their
lives the boat they traveled in the
remains of which were found later is
thought to have come from germany and we
know smuggler supply chains operate well
beyond calais which is why this summit
was all about a broader european
approach
we agreed to have an even closer
cooperation between the member states
and the commission via our agencies and
to be able to deploy for example
airplane also standing cores if
necessary to work closer also on returns
and on police cooperation
it was in many ways an unprecedented
meeting and where there was no big
announcement there was solidarity on
this side of the channel ali forsky sky
news in calais
teenage boy is to appear in court later
on today after being charged with the
murder of 12 year old ava white in
liverpool the 14 year old who can't be
named for legal reasons was also charged
with possession of a blade while three
other boys between the ages of 13 and 15
who were arrested have been released on
bail ava was killed in the city center
on thursday after meeting friends to
watch the christmas lights being
switched on
the artistic director of louis vuitton
virgil abloh has died of cancer at the
age of 41. the designer made history in
2018 as the first african-american to
lead louis vuitton the world's biggest
luxury brand ablo also worked as a dj
and visual artist and the rapper and
producer farrell williams is among the
names paying tribute
he said my heart is broken virgil you
were a kind generous thoughtful creative
genius your work as a human and your
work as a spiritual being will live
forever sending love and light to your
wife children family
and day ones
you're
with the master now shine
quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's absolutely freezing this morning
minus two as i got into uh the car so if
you are heading out you can see a clear
skies some rain on its way from the west
but make sure that you wrap up more
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and we'll be chatting to some people in
yorkshire who've now had their third
night in a pub where they are completely
snowed in it was karaoke night last
night apparently i wonder what they were
singing went to wonderland doubt it uh
we'll be talking to them um but did you
catch some of the snow this weekend
where you were many of us have been out
enjoying the colder weather well perhaps
maybe not enjoying it quite as much as
this pair of polar bears captured in
central uh canada 60 of the world's
polar bear population can be found in
canada and these two were spotted in
churchill manitoba which has been
nicknamed the polar bear capital of the
world
having an absolute
just hearing from the world health
organization actually they have um just
issued a statement by the reuters news
agency saying depending on the
characteristics of the omicron uh
variant there could be future surges of
curvid 19 which could have severe
consequences that is what the world
health organization is saying uh within
the last few moments and suggesting that
people take that into consideration when
they are planning to travel over the
next few days and weeks meantime with
plans to restrict the spread of the
variant in the uk set to go before
parliament the government has admitted
that it expects the number of cases to
rise here as well the health minister ed
argher told me a short while ago that
measures set to be introduced will not
stop the spread of the new strain you'll
have seen in the news overnight three
confirmed cases i'll be honest with you
and your viewers i would expect that to
rise um we don't know by what speed or
by what numbers so therefore what we're
doing is trying to slow it down but
we're clear we can't stop it and we're
trying to give ourselves the time to
understand how it works and how it
interacts
with the vaccine but that's why we're
putting in place these sensible
precautionary measures to help slow it
down
well the minister also told me that the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization should be making a decision
at some point today on extending the
booster program to all ages and
shortening the gap between second and
third vaccinations
the secretary of state sergey javid as
you will know has asked the jcvi the
joint committee on vaccinations and
immunizations for advice urgently on a
the uh
bringing down the gap potentially
between
first between second and booster jabs
but also in terms of whether the booster
program should be extended downwards in
terms of age range we're awaiting that
advice i hope it will come hopefully
later today i don't want to pre-judge it
i don't know what our understanding is
that it's anybody over 18 gets a booster
but i think that's what they are looking
at i don't know what they're going to
recommend i haven't seen the advice you
you and your team may have done but i
haven't yet because i don't think it's
been formally delivered but we'd expect
that within the next within the coming
hours okay so sometime today we'll hear
that's my what's happening and the gap
between the second booster and that
second vaccine and the booster that
could come down to five months
potentially but we'll wait for their
advice that's that's what they're there
for and we will look very carefully
advice they give us hopefully in the
next few
hours tomorrow's here good morning good
morning um lots to talk to the minister
about this morning it's really it's you
know
they say that the government says that
they've moved quickly to try to sort
this uh problem out but it's it's you
know six and two threes at this stage
isn't it well as we discovered with
previous variants k once you see a
couple of cases the likelihood is it
spread much further than we expected and
that's why in the past they have been
slower to put countries on the red list
because they say once a variant is
present it's probably present in a lot
of different countries in this case
they've put restrictions on south africa
and several other african countries but
the clear message is that
the government expects the number of
cases to rise the uncertainty is how
quickly it rises how transmissible is
this variant compared to the delta
variant and how serious is the disease
that it causes because south africa has
a younger population than ours so those
are the two unknowns which they hope
will become much clearer in the next two
to three weeks but until we know that
there are more restrictions first of all
we expect today the government to
announce that all over 18s can get a
booster once they have had the proper
time interval since their second jab not
sure that will necessarily be reduced to
five months we'll see on that so
boosters to be expanded to give everyone
a bit more immunity to the virus we're
also going to see measures in schools
from today secondary school pupils
having to wear their masks in communal
corridors and so on and from tomorrow
we've got regulations before parliament
today mask wearing in shops not in pubs
and restaurants but insurance why not i
thought really clear
i think um although that is the rule in
indoor settings in scotland and wales
the minister seemed to think it was
impractical in venues where people are
eating and drinking i think they they
think that
in terms of ensuring compliance they
think it will be easier in shops and on
transport and also
if omicron spreads and there are a lot
of cases anyone who's been in contact
with an omicron case will have to
self-isolate no matter what their
vaccination status so that is something
to watch because if the number of cases
gets into the hundreds or thousands we
could see problems with that in schools
and workplaces perhaps even a return to
the ping demk of a few months ago but
that is uh that is for later for the
moment these are restrictions which
ministers believe will slow the spread
while we get to grips with how serious
it is and this will become law the mass
this will become your yes yeah and
there'll be fines of 200 pounds at least
if you don't comply yeah he did say that
he didn't see didn't envisage any
tougher restrictions than the ones that
are presently in place that's what was
interesting that's right they don't
envision anything tougher for the next
three weeks sajid javed the health
secretary says he hopes to lift some of
these restrictions in the next three
weeks but there is so much uncertainty
about this at the moment about how
severe it is how transmissible it is and
how effective crucially the vaccines are
against it scientists say of course it's
worth having your booster that will give
you some protection but if it's less
protection than against delta that is
one of the things that they're looking
at okay tomorrow tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock look forward to it thank you now
it's been a difficult few weeks for the
government and the conservative party of
course from allegations of sleaze to
controversial changes to the social care
cap and this week an unresolved approach
to migration policy resulting in human
tragedy in the english channel the first
real public test of how people feel
about all of it will come next week when
voters of old bexley and sikkaput a
long-held safe conservative seat elect a
new mp our deputy political editor sam
coats has been there talking to people
and sent this report
a visionary not for the last three weeks
doubts in westminster tension over big
decisions
massive spending on transport for the
north 96 billion pounds nothing like it
again nothing like it overshadowed by
broken promises
were the voters of the north right to
take the prime minister at his word
a long-term policy failure they promised
to fix unresolved meaning human tragedy
in the channel this disaster
underscores how dangerous it is to cross
the channel anger that the least well
off got a worse deal on social care it's
another broken promise and concern as to
whether the prime minister was quite at
the top of his game this week in a major
speech has anybody's been to pep a big
world
not enough
leading to uncomfortable questioning
is everything okay prime minister
to test that important question does any
of this make a difference in the country
we asked voters in the south london seat
of old bexley and sidcup where there is
a by-election next week i've always
voted tori always voted for it and
events of the last few days
yes they've made me wobbly a little bit
and why is that
i just don't trust boris i just don't
think the man's got a grip what do you
think of the last two weeks
not very good why
why um
i don't think he's giving people
confidence at the moment
because there's a lot with immigration
there's a lot lots of things he's done
very good
but all of a sudden i think he's gone
off the boil have you voted for him in
the past i have and what
started to change your mind about what
you think of it um well he's fumbling
around a lot i think
i'm talking about peppa pig do you think
what you've seen even the last few weeks
is going to change the way you vote next
week probably not
it's not that the voters around here
don't know about the sleaze scandals the
migrant boat crisis or the stumbles in
the prime minister's speech
unlike some politicians however they
take a longer view
mps can wobble voters
seem to hold their nerve
holding their nerve because voters point
to and care about the assistance
government gave to individuals and small
businesses over the last two years of
the pandemic is there's anything he
could do that would mean he probably get
your vote next time
oh god
um
probably not no
in westminster northern mps like andrew
percy who voted against his government
this week worry about its direction
there are too many issues at the moment
in which the government is shooting
itself in the foot with with with issues
and problems which as i say colleagues
are warning warning and warning about
and that are visible from venus mars
even maybe even visible from pluto and
that has got to stop because we owe the
people of this country better than that
many mps are concerned boris johnson
promised big but is struggling to
deliver and this also applies to boats
crossing the channel there's a genuine
concern that the government has talked
tough quite rightly the government
genuinely wants this trade to end as we
all uh do
but we haven't been able to achieve that
on our own because most of the cards are
in the hands of the french and perhaps
it was unwise to over promise
when we couldn't rely on the sort of
partnership that we need a by-election
here next week and another in two weeks
that will tell us whether the country
shares the concerns of boris johnson's
mps
sam coates sky news
of course some of the team will be
covering that story for us throughout
the time between now and the by-election
who knows what might happen we'll cover
it for you here on sky um something else
we've been covering for you over the
last couple of months is what's going on
with that um volcano there it is on um
la palma
lava spewing from a new opening on the
kombre vieja volcano on sunday as the
eruption entered its tenth
week my goodness me scientists from the
canary islands volcanological institute
it's how to say on a monday morning said
the new vent opened overnight allowing
huge clouds of smoke to blow into the
sky it comes after la palomas airport
recently reopened after cleaning
services dispersed much of the ash cloud
from the atmosphere local authorities
say the lavas damaged more than two and
a half thousand buildings and displaced
thousands of people from their homes
looks pretty dramatic still doesn't that
we did hear from a volcanologist who
said that it would continue to be active
until after christmas coming up going to
be speaking to the chair of the south
african medical association the doctor
who first spotted the new omicron
variant
[Music]
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school can help stop toxic
air getting trapped in our classrooms
[Music]
there'll be a cold frosty start to the
day for many inland areas although
there'll be a few rogue showers over
eastern coastal counties increasing
cloud over scotland and ireland will
bring patchy rain that will fall as snow
on its leading edge
through the day rain will spread
southwards with blustery showers
following the southern half of the
country will stay fine through much of
the day although cloud will increase
from the north
air quality will remain low in these
changing conditions ranging between 1
and 3 on the air pollution scale
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
when pupils go back to school this
morning they'll be required to wear
masks in communal areas the advice from
the government follows confirmation of a
third case of the omicron variant in the
uk
scientists are concerned that the new
strain of coronavirus could be resistant
to vaccines and the new measures are
intended to slow its spread people are
also being asked to wear masks in shops
and on public transport although those
rules don't formally come into force
until tomorrow ender brady has this
report
the omicron variant is here but how do
we stop it from spreading
face coverings will be mandatory for
pupils staff and visitors from this
morning in communal areas of secondary
schools some teachers unions say that
isn't enough vaccination is going to be
a really important part of the solution
to this
but we haven't yet even offered
vaccination to half of those secondary
age pupils
so this makes it all the more clear that
the government should have invested in
ventilation and air filtration i think
they were hoping that the vaccination
that we were seeing the end of delta we
were going to get away with it
and we all wish that that was true
from tomorrow face coverings will be
compulsory in shops banks post offices
and hairdressers as well as on public
transport
all travellers arriving into the country
from 4am regardless of vaccination
status will be required to take a pcr
test on or before day two
they'll have to self-isolate until they
receive a negative result we're showing
that we're worried about it by the
actions that have been rapidly taken by
the uk government but also by other
governments around the world it has more
mutations than anything we've seen
before and some of those mutations are
in areas of the virus that will
particularly affect the immune response
updated advice from the joint committee
on vaccination and immunization on
expanding the booster program is also
imminent
later today an urgent meeting of g7
health ministers will take place with
just one topic on the agenda
how to tackle a variant that could
derail all the progress that has been
made so far in this pandemic ender brady
sky news
with plans to restrict the spread of the
omicron variant in the uk set to go
before parliament the government has
admitted that it expects the number of
cases to rise the health minister edward
argo told me just a short while ago
actually that measures set to be
introduced will not stop the spread of
the new strain
you'll have seen in the news overnight
three confirmed cases i'll be honest
with you and your viewers i would expect
that to rise um we don't know by what
speed or by what numbers so therefore
what we're doing is trying to slow it
down but we're clear we can't stop it
and we're trying to give ourselves the
time to understand how it works and how
it interacts
with the vaccine but that's why we're
putting in place these sensible
precautionary measures to help slow it
down
well the minister also told me that the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization jcvi you've heard that
acronym should be making a decision at
some point today on extending the
booster program to all ages and then
shortening the gap between the second
and the third vaccinations
the secretary of state sergey javid as
you will know has asked the jcvi the
joint committee on vaccinations and
immunizations for advice urgently on a
the
bringing down the gap potentially
between
first between second and booster jabs
but also in terms of whether the booster
program should be extended downwards in
terms of age range we're awaiting that
advice i hope it will come um hopefully
later today i don't want to pre-judge it
i don't know so our understanding is
that it's anybody over 18 gets a booster
but i think that's what they are looking
at i don't know what they're going to
recommend i haven't seen the advice you
you and your team may have done but i
haven't yet because i don't think it's
been formally delivered but we'd expect
that within the next within the coming
hours okay so sometime today we'll hear
from that's my what's
and the gap between the second booster
and the second vaccine and the booster
that could come down to five months
potentially but we'll we'll wait for
their advice that's that's what they're
there for and we will look very
carefully advice they give us hopefully
in the next few hours
tamara is here uh yeah so sergey javid
asked the jcbi to look at this urgently
we'll hear later on today what they're
planning to do we believe um what's
labour saying about all this so labour
have said on saturday that they believe
that they've been very much in favor of
extending boosters and also of having
more restrictions i expect these
these are these new measures on masks to
sail through parliament tomorrow but um
they've also said that they want the gap
between the second jab and the booster
to be reduced to five months it's not
clear what the official advice is going
to be on that today and it's almost
certain the government will follow
whatever that advice is they've also for
months now been saying that they feel
that there should be masks in more
indoor settings in england as there are
in scotland in scotland if you go to a
bar or restaurant you do have to wear
your mask in wales you have to wear them
in most indoor settings not hospitality
but certainly in cinemas and theaters
and so on that is not going to be the
case in england so labour have said that
the government should have kept more of
those rules a mandatory mask wearing
indoors so i'm sure we'll see a bit of i
told you so and kierstama has also
talked about people who can work from
home doing so that is not a route the
government wants to go down unless it's
a last resort because they know that it
has a big economic impact yeah
interestingly that the government think
that you can't catch covey in the pub
that's right edward argher the health
minister said they believe that
mandating masks on public transport and
in shops is a common sense approach and
it's proportionate because in venues
where people are eating and drinking
taking them off putting them on again
it's not very practical but they make it
work in scotland in other european
countries people are wearing their masks
when they go into a restaurant and
taking them off when they sit at the
table as was the case in england at an
earlier stage of the pandemic so the
government are trying to go for perhaps
the lowest hanging fruit in terms of
things that people can do and especially
since they want to back this up with
fines it's easier to see someone in a
shop not wearing a mask and say you
should have a fine than for example
someone in a pub who may have taken
theirs off to have a drink and then
needed to put it on again so i think
it's a question of enforcement and what
feels most
realistic to enforce now i know you'll
do all this more in tomorrow's take
coming up at the top of the nine o'clock
hour but um
could we see any tighter restrictions
between now and christmas no one's ruled
it out it would be it would be in the
view of most ministers um wrong to rule
out anything at this stage when there's
so much unknown about the omicron
variant we simply don't know whether
it's going to be more transmissible than
the delta variant that's obviously going
to be crucial for how fast it spreads
how
severe will be the disease that it
causes so far not very serious but
that's in young people in south africa
it's not spread yet among older people
and then of course
whether the vaccines are as effective as
they have been against other strains so
all these things they hope will be clear
in the next two to three weeks sajid
javid told um sky news yesterday that
everyone could expect to have a great
christmas i'm sure that that's probably
going to be under review over the next
few weeks well let's see tomorrow thanks
very much indeed thanks a lot what's
going to happen as far as schools are
concerned children uh over a certain age
yes seven will have to wear masks becky
is at a school in birmingham for us
hello becky good morning so what's the
plan
yeah so we're hearing that from today
staff and students year seven and above
so secondary school students will have
to wear masks in school
this was a policy earlier in the year
when that phase return began after
lockdown but they removed that
recommendation for mass and it is just a
recommendation it's not compulsory at
the moment but they have now brought
that back in because of concerns about
this new variant now i'm at bristol hall
academy in birmingham and i've got the
principal here collie oppel now cully do
you think that it would be better if
masks were in the classrooms as well
because at the moment this does just
apply to the communal areas doesn't it
well the guidance has just only been
released on saturday we have
communicated with parents this morning
to say that the mass should be worn in
corridors and communal areas and of
course we'll continue to follow the
guidance to ensure that students are as
safe as possible as well as our staff
too so if that's the classrooms later on
we'll certainly follow that too yeah
because of course covey doesn't
differentiate between corridors and
classrooms does it it doesn't know and
that's why we say we closely follow the
guidance to ensure that safety is of
absolute paramount importance and there
have been calls that students should be
exempt from having to isolate if they
come into contact with someone who has
tested positive with this new omicron
variant do you agree with that would you
prefer to see students in school even if
they do come into contact with someone
who's tested positive for their variants
well i think that needs to be remain
with the scientists really who give us
the best support those those are medical
experts because of course our most
important factor is keep them safe we
ensure that they continue to learn and
if they do have to isolate here at
bristol hall academy we'll ensure that
learning continues remotely via whatever
package it is that's in place and
obviously students have already missed a
lot of school time because of covert do
you worry you will have to close early
before christmas there aren't any
indications of that just yet however as
we say and it sounds like a repeated
line always that we continue to follow
the guidance but if that was the case
and is that something that was the
decision that was taken we'll ensure
that the learning continues because our
students must make sure they get the
best provision of course all the time
thank you mr oppel and kate we'll be
bringing you more from bristol hall
academy throughout the morning we're
expecting the students to arrive any
minute and from today they will be
having to wear masks in communal areas
okay lovely thank you thanks a lot quick
look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
cloud and rain spreading in from the
northwest will introduce a brief spell
of milder air but colder conditions will
return later in the week
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways